Apple is apologizing after admitting a
software update deliberately slowed some
older iPhones the tech giant says the
update is intended to prevent sudden
shutdowns in the iPhone 6 but as a side
effect apps and other functions run
slower in a new message to customers the
company says quote we know that some of
you feel Apple has let you down we
apologize we have never and would never
do anything to intentionally shorten the
life of any Apple product Apple is
discounting the cost of battery
replacements on certain phones Dan
Ackerman is a section editor at our
partners CNET Dan great to have you back
with us at the table this is a bit
confusing Apple is apologizing but not
for what some of its users are accusing
it of doing so explain how this all went
down it's a complicated issue what Apple
did was come up with a not entirely
unreasonable solution to a problem
that's not very easy to fix and that's
the batteries that we use in everything
as they get older they don't hold as
much charge and they also can't give out
energy at the same peak levels and when
you have newer apps on phones that
really want to do impressive stuff they
need a lot of energy and people found
that on their older phones sometimes not
only was the battery life not as long
the phone would just shut down I found
that happened to me with my iPhone 6
plus so they had a software update
because so many things about these
devices are determined by by software
updates that come after you buy the
original device that said we're gonna
we're gonna smooth out some of those
peaks do some power management to
basically say the phone can't give out
as much energy to the apps as the apps
may sometimes ask for to make the
battery last longer so you don't have a
phone that lasts like three or four
hours you have one that'll last most of
the day you know it's interesting
because this did make me think when I
read this story when you used to have a
blackberry you can actually take the
battery out yourself and put a new one
in with the iPhone it's not easy to do
you'd actually have to go into the store
and have it done for you Apple is now
saying they're going to allow you to
follow your battery life more easier
easily on your iPhone explain that yes
they're not going to change what the
software update did in terms of doing
the power management and slowing down
your phone to extend the battery life
but they say that they're going to add
something to the software for it that
will let you monitor it and give you
more information more transparency
about what's happening and and that's
kind of the entire game here is
providing transparency that's one that
the polity does after the fact and
that's what I think people were more
upset about and then their older phones
slowing down a bit that the lack of
transparency that they weren't telling
you they were doing this to your product
you mentioned the apology how big of a
deal was that we heard sort of a little
apology and now a full apology that's
true an Apple over the years I've had a
handful of these situations where
they've done these kind of big apologies
the one that always comes to mind is
what they call antenna gate which was
actually way back 8010 where first they
said you're holding the phone wrong if
you can't get a call through and then
they said okay we'll give you a little
rubber bumper to go around and we're
sorry about that so it is rare but
apology to think are very important for
these big companies look what happened
with Samsung last year when they had
their own battery problems they
eventually came to a big apology a big
investigation shared a lot of
information with people and now people
are still buying Samsung the you know
galaxy and note phones that apology
really worked well for them you and I
have had conversations about there's a
lot of people have a sneaking suspicion
that the reason that these phones didn't
work is so that you would be forced to
upgrade to the newest model of an iPhone
is Apple addressing that they've denied
that by the way I think what they were
trying to do at least what they say they
were trying to do is the opposite make
your phone feel like it'll last longer
because the battery doesn't run out as
quickly and you don't feel like you have
to get a new phone but by making the
phones feel more sluggish they actually
ended up maybe doing the opposite I had
an iPhone six-plus that was really
getting kind of pokey and I upgraded to
a 10 this year when I gave my six to
somebody I work with the first thing
they did was go oh man you've got to get
a new phone really slow to them it's
rare you get an apology from Apple and
while they did offer an apology they
also explained in their apologies with
batteries in laughs yeah yeah and it's
true and this batteries and everything
we own not just phones it is the
sluggishness that leads to all of us to
new purchases Dan Ackerman thank you
very much okay